austin gomber also gives you a good
feeling because he's been so solid
had a no decision on saturday against
the cubs went two and two-thirds innings
only gave up one hit
they'd have some control issues which i
think sometimes happen
when you go back from being a reliever
to a starter maybe you're overthrowing a
little bit
push spun by victor reyes to the right
side and he's going to get a bunt single
wong came in try to scoop it and shovel
it with his glove
we haven't seen victor reyes do that all
year a leadoff bunt single here in the
first well good idea
boy did it work somebody recognized
something that's a push butt with good
speed nobody can make the play
double play ball four six
three on the double play dug out by
goldschmidt today's starting pitcher for
the tigers is
jordan zimmerman last season was not
good he was hurt he hurt that right
forearm
first start of the year really been
rehabbing that for some time
the runner goes to uh third base brad
miller will be the
batter he's hitting 282 has five homers
and 21 rbis
swinging to miss he got him with a high
fastball boy good pitching
brad miller strikes out and jordan
zimmerman after the first two reach
gets a double play in a strikeout we go
to the second inning scoreless in st
louis so uh the cardinals scored seven
in the second inning in the first game
they're off to a good start in this one
they have runners at second and third
no one out carpenter into center field
sinking that's a base hit
and a run will score and it's one to
one-to-nothing cardinals on the base hit
by matt carpenter just dropped it into
center
and it's one-to-nothing cardinals and on
man out in the third inning heading into
the heart of the order
swinging a line drive to right field
that's deep and that's trouble cameron
going back reached out makes the catch
bangs into the wall and hangs on throws
back to first he won't be able to double
off the base runner admin what a great
play
by dez cameron racing under the warning
track
and reaching just as he hit the wall
that was a frozen rope everybody that
young man we told you
he's loaded with talent and that ball
was hit over his head he got back there
quickly and reached up with the last bit
second
take an extra base hit away from maybe a
run even the bases will be
loaded and nobody out for detroit this
is almost like a closer situation
in a seventh inning game and this is
could be where the game is right here in
the fourth
popped up infield fly and the catch is
made that is a big big
out cameron not a good selection on his
part two and oh
to be taking a pitch that's off the
plate or on the corner
instead of something he could drive
greiner has grounded into two double
plays
swing and a miss that takes care of
grinder out number two
half swing and a liner to third caught
by carpenter
the tigers had the bases loaded nobody
out didn't score and we go to the bottom
of the fourth
carpenter singled in the cardinals run
in the second inning scoring paul to
young
and carpenter drives it in the gap into
right center field that goal is down
one hops off the wall a run will score
that's to young
matt carpenter is brought in two in game
two two nothing saint louis
and he handles this 3-2 pitch and the
cardinals get a break now carpenter
does most of the work but that ball does
not bounce over the wall
if it bounces over the wall then it's a
ground rule double
and the young has to stay at third so
that could have gone either way i was
afraid of that big hop and thankfully it
stayed in the ballpark for matt
two ouch in the fifth for tommy edmund
edmond with a fly ball
out to deep left it's at the wall it's
gone
off of big mac land tommy edmonds
showing some power
how about that power for tommy edmond
his fourth home run of the season
and it's a three-run st louis lead
and that's a big one two quick outs a
home run three-nothing cardinals here in
the fifth inning
low must be a low ball hitter that's
where that pitch was and boy did he
tommy huck that baby
with a terrific uppercut that went out
by a long one you can hit it over the
the bullpen and left that's a mighty
blast one-on-one on jamer candelario
sixth inning tigers need base runners he
swings and drives on to centerfield deep
vader on the run out of the track
looking up and it's gone a home run
jamer candelario does it again a home
run in game one
from the left side a home run in game
two from the right side tigers are on
the board now trailing three to one well
he got a fastball
out over the plate he did not miss it
which he has been on such a role he does
not miss many at all
it's still just a 3-1 game though i i
i'm just wondering about matt
fly ball into left center this ball in
the gap and
a sliding catcher want to play again
bonifacio with a sliding catch on the
track
wow two great defensive plays by tiger
outfielders in this game first mike dez
cameron
and now jorge bonifacio robs
lane thomas of an extra base hit runners
at first and second
jonathan the scope had to play the
strike once you mean a shot off the
midland to centerfield a base hit
rounding third heading home is alcantara
the throw comes all the way through it's
way off line hits miguel
next to the home plate throw it on to
third and not in time
reyes got in we've got a 3-2 game that's
the medical team
talking to giovanni gallegos and that's
going to be it
oh boy games can turn on a dime and this
one has
so the bases are loaded nobody out now
they're
asking hellsly to have a houdini act of
his own
drive base hit into center field in the
score comes reyes
scoping waved around third he's coming
home thrown not in time
jamer candelario delivers again
two runs single how about it
tigers have scored three in the ninth to
take a 4-3 lead
you cannot make it up he is so good hill
the pinch runner for cabrera's at second
base
first pitch to bonifacio is swinging a
fly ball left field
deep o'neal going back to the warning
track looking up and it's going a home
run
jorge bonifacio with number two
big two run shot with two outs in the
seventh
and the tigers now lead at six to three
you talk about where to hang in breaking
balls go they go out of the ball parky
went out in a hurry
grinder setting up low and away righty
on righty matchup garcia from the
stretch the 1-1
swinging the fly ball right field deep
into the corner daz cameron will reach
out make the catch disappear from our
view and hang on
tigers win beautiful